et
regardez dehors
bienvenue à matra ni les amis
merci beaucoup de nous recevoir c'est
une belle occasion pour moi de renouer
avec les filles
c'est maman qui les a pris tu vois ce
type remparts ont dit c'est toi elle me
manque encore tous les jours
c'est quoi ça quelque chose vient de
traverser
dans la voiture d'accord resté dans la
voiture il tient bien voir d'abord au
hockey qu'est ce qu'il a dit diabolo ça
veut dire le diable
j'ai jamais vu une chose pareille
des attaques nombreuses sans dévorer sa
proie les lions font pas ça en tout cas
occasion que j'ai vu
retourne auprès des filles
allez
l'ontario
oui
et
respire respire lanta
maintenant on est sur son territoire
c'est la loi de la jungle c'est la seule
loi qui compte
ils ont des armes vous avez rien à faire
ici qu'est ce que vous faites
il faut que je sorte mes fiches de là
vous devez me faire confiance matin
je vais revenir
ne bougez pas d'accord